[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are finally able to talk
in specific what we've been talking
about liking code and in general
generalities over the past few months
we're going to be discussing our we dug
a medium-sized hole video that we just
launched on the Rhett and Link channel
yes the original Rhett and Link channel
which I would say
if you haven't watched the video yet
this episode of ear biscuits will be
that much more enjoyable yeah if you
just pause
and go watch the video it is about 26
minutes long at least
the current cut which we assume is what
we ended up releasing I don't think you
have to see if you don't have to yeah it
would it you know you could and if
you're not going to you should still
listen to this because then I don't
think going and watching the videos
we're going and watching the video will
be that much more enjoyable from a
different perspective if you listen to
this first I prefer that you watch it
before and after and during what we want
is we want uh to listen on this and the
watch on the other thing you know what's
up that's what we're asking for from for
of you here's how I'm gonna
uh set up this episode okay well what if
I want to set it up completely
differently well you've already set it
up
so now my version is this is a
creative celebration episode if you dear
ear brisketeer have ever had an idea
or ever created something and
um
to me the point of Celebration is when
you're finished I just so happened to be
listening to uh
Rick rubin's book
on Audible
what's it called again the creative act
the way of the creative active way of
being I think yeah which you recommended
a while back I've been listening to it
and he was talking about
um creative success and success is the
point where you've completed something
and then you're about to put it out into
the world
it's not Commercial Success which is
like making money off something or
um getting the response any other type
of success that is getting a desired
response from an audience like I I'm
glad that we're recording this podcast
at the point where we're actually we
actually haven't completed the entire
video like we've basically we edit but
the music is not final and uh the
dramatic death scene we haven't seen
spoiler
wow that's a teaser yes there's a death
scene and it may be one of us
um is not well I haven't seen that Final
Cut either
but we kind of know how this thing is
going to fully come together and we know
in the next couple of days it is going
to come together and by the time you're
listening to this it's already out into
the world but that's my point is that
this is a celebration of
having an idea and there's a lot of
stuff that I I imagine we'll talk about
that led up to this particular idea and
the fact that we're relaunching videos
on the Rhett and Link channel this year
um a lot goes into that there's a lot
behind it and this is the first of many
videos
but it's the perfect time to celebrate
it because we did it
we set out to do it and we did it we can
later celebrate whether people get it
whether mythical beasts like it if we
want to but that's a separate thing if
we rob ourselves of something very
precious if we don't stop and celebrate
the fact that
we did make it
we set out to make it and we made it and
I'm very very happy with it and it makes
me very happy
period so that's it that I mean I think
that's that's because because I did I
did fall into this trap of like why I
kind of wish we could record this after
we knew what people thought about it so
we could like respond to it it's like
[__] that
you know it's like that's not create
that's not
that robs us of this creative
celebration that is now and if so back
to what I was saying if you've ever had
an idea if you've ever thought about
doing something taking a risk making
something whether it's for an audience
or not that's beside the point
um
would you join us in a celebration today
of
expressing
ourselves
and I'm talking about you too I
celebrate you for whatever risk you're
taking to put yourself out there to
nobody somebody or a lot of people
whatever it is it could be anything I
bet it I bet there's a creative element
to it and I agree that the uh it's great
to talk about this before we get the
response because we have been in uh
we've been playing this game there's the
creative side right and then there's
sort of the gamesmanship side of what we
do as a career because obviously you
couldn't really do anything creative as
a career
um if there wasn't some way for you to
make money off of it right if not enough
people liked it that we could be able to
do this for a living then we'd just be
doing it as a hobby so we're blessed
with the fact that people have responded
well enough to a lot of things that
we've created in the past that we sort
of have this Baseline in this audience
that we can kind of release things out
into but
I do think there is a distinct
difference between the way that we're
viewing the content that we're creating
now starting with this video and there's
more in the works right now
as it isn't designed
I mean hopefully it'll be a success in
the traditional sense right but
it is not that is not the first thought
you know good mythical morning is this
uh thing where we've got this team we've
got this system we have this very well
oil machine that puts out this show and
we're going into our 12th year and we've
gotten to this place that it's this
perfect environment and set up for us to
be ourselves we have a great time making
the show we've never been having more
fun hopefully that's coming through
and it continues to be a commercial
success and it kind of has to be a
commercial success for the amount of
uh effort in the team and the salaries
and all that that goes into it right
right and the Ambitions we have Beyond
it that are fueled by it right but this
thing that we're working on now this
we'll talk about how it came about and
then how this specific idea came about
and talk about some of the stuff that
you may not the questions that you might
have by just watching it
this was this idea that we've been
talking about in this nebulous way of
soul-driven content of doing things for
the creative act
for the sake of creativity which we've
done a bunch of things for the sake of
creativity over the past decade and a
half
but we have found ourselves in this
place where we've got this thing that
people know us for namely GMM currently
we've done a lot of things in the past
that people might still remember but in
terms of like current programming the
thing that you would know us from is
Good Mythical Morning
and then we've always had these
Ambitions to do these more substantial
more creative things because we've said
many times GMM isn't really about us
being creative it's about us being
ourselves and having a good time and and
our team creating an atmosphere for us
right but we got into this business
because we wanted to create art we
wanted to do we had ideas that we wanted
to bring into the world we have all
kinds of creative Ambitions and we've
been
you know in the early days we funneled
those into a series of videos whether
those be music videos or local
commercials or sketches and all these
you know throwing all this stuff at the
wall that ended up enabling us to create
a career out of the out of this
but once we got out here to uh
California we got these things running
we got mythical up and running we start
and also the the Dynamics of the way
that YouTube worked and the way and the
things that they were rewarding kind of
shifted a little bit but we've been like
we've been creating a lot of stuff if
you go back over the past 10 years or so
it's like yo wrote a book wrote a novel
tried to develop that novel into a TV
show wrote a pilot for that TV show
ended up shifting and having somebody
else try to Pilot for that TV show wrote
a couple of Pilots with a couple of
people wrote a pile on our own wrote a
feature film came up with all these
different things that we've been doing
over the past year and it has been this
process of
going across town getting into a room
with a traditional Network Outlet or
whatever and trying to convince them
that we're worthy of making something on
their terms and having to overcome the
stigma of being a YouTuber being guys
who eat weird stuff on the internet
whatever
and so we finally said let's stop trying
to play that game and recognize that we
have an audience that we can create for
um and let's go back and
do this through the Rhett and Link
channel because it's just going to
sitting there waiting you know and so
this video sort of represents step one
in that direction and there's a lot more
to come in the near future
I feel the need to step back and
uh on some not to pull back but to
clarify something that I said you know
when I said like
F that earlier it was like waiting to
celebrate
uh creating something like waiting to
celebrate this video's release
if based on the reaction that it gets or
how many how it performs
um yeah I'm saying screw that like we
can celebrate now the creative act
does that mean that
audience doesn't matter does that mean
that their reaction is not something
that I'm curious about or that in
certain contexts doesn't matter no way
no way but
I feel like we are making this is a
trust exercise we are expressing
ourselves and then trusting that like
that's the best thing we can do and
people's response to it
uh whether they're a long-term aligned
fan or just a passerby
across the entire Spectrum it's like
that's that's now that we've made the
thing and we've put it out there that
part's beyond our control I think that
we and we owe it
to the mythical beasts to make things
that we believe in and that we're
passionate about we owe it to them to do
things that
we want to do
and not do things just because we think
that they want it you know there's
nothing about this particular video
that's controversial that's going to get
some negative reaction it may some
people may scratch their heads uh people
can be critical any way they want uh
because and I'm fine with that because
it it demonstrates this level of care
for about what we do it turns into
criticism and
that's even okay you know so I'm even
choosing to see whatever criticism comes
in this thing as something that is
it's just a demonstration of care you're
not going to criticize something if you
don't care about it
especially when it's like there's nobody
professionally criticizing any of our
work you know it's just people who do it
from a passionate standpoint
but we owe it to our fans to make things
that we want to make yeah and
put our heart and soul into it
you know and not just try to Pander to
them or this is not you know we're not
we're not providing a service with this
with this uh this these videos we're
putting out on this channel right you
know and but if it resonates with you
and it and it moves you then that's
great I mean I do have certain desired
outcomes
for this thing but I'm separating myself
from that and allowing myself to
um to celebrate what we've got I I do
think that's important from a from a
from a creative standpoint I don't think
I'm not I'm not crapping on I just don't
want it to seem like I'm crapping on
fans in the process I know I I think
it's a win-win I I think not only yes it
actually what is best for them uh and
when it comes to this content is what we
fee what we personally feel the best
about because that's what this
particular exercise is but I also think
yes this is this is a different strategy
this is we are taking creative joy in
the thing that we're creating and
obviously it would be super awesome and
encouraging if people resonated with it
and people's response to if we're gonna
throw
a bunch of stuff at the wall this year
well if we resonate with something and
the fans don't resonate with it we are
less likely to dip back into that well
because that it you know we are going to
there is going to be a little bit of a
dance but when it comes to an individual
idea the execution of the idea and how
we feel about it when it's done
the most important thing is how we feel
about it when it's done and then there's
a secondary thing is how people respond
to it yeah that's specifically the
strategy with this content and there's
no shame in that and
listen to the way that we're talking
about this it's like it means so much to
us like I am so engaged in this uh with
so much of my being like every part of
my being feels like is activated
uh this is this is
um
it's an enlivening process to to to
dream up something and then to do it now
all that being said and as serious as
we've been talking about it it's a video
about digging a medium-sized Hull yeah
that's it
and we and we did that on purpose right
so both of these things are true so like
we want to have like this pure creative
expression and then we but it just felt
important
that
we didn't
we didn't make it too self-important
we actually made it anti-important I
mean there's irony in the fact that like
we're
we're removing all these like
all of the the boxes that you would
check in order to make something
successful on the internet as a video
sensationalism
um
controversy
uh
I mean nudity I don't know fill in the
blank well whatever you want to fill in
the blank with that we are we we kind of
shunned all those things to make it more
of a creative
exercise and so and not take ourselves
too seriously so I do acknowledge we're
taking this very seriously
so at the same time we didn't want to
take ourselves we don't we you know we
got to have the other side of that coin
let's just dig a medium-sized hole
well I think what else keep this
inconsequential I I heard recently
um I'm not going to make this my wreck
and so I won't tell you where I heard it
because it's your wreck and I and I'm
going to save this record you're going
to respect that I I have found a a
source of creative inspiration that I
will talk about later but oh uh this one
artist was uh basically said don't take
yourself seriously but take your work
very seriously and I think that that is
I like that that is
that that really embodies the way that
we're seeing what we're doing I mean
obviously we're going to sit here and
we're going to talk about it as if it's
important enough to do a podcast about
but we've sort of uh the fact is is that
most if you're listening to this podcast
on a regular basis you've made the
decision that we at least talk about
things that you care about enough
to have the right to then talk about
this stuff but yeah
to talk about a medium-sized hole as if
it's the best thing on the planet we'll
get into the details but I do want to
talk about the details of what I'm
wearing right now uh yes this is from
what we're calling the mythical
Evergreen collection and I guess that
means that we're going to keep it around
for a while so essentially these are you
know a little bit understated uh teas
that have the embroidered M it's got a
little sheen on it also the embroidered
mythical logo on the right sleeve and it
comes in this color which is Olive it
also comes in Black Ivory and mustard
and this is if you're just like hey
there's some hats too there's a hat and
a hat coming in I want to represent
mythical but I don't necessarily
question about it no questions just
class yeah get all this and more at
mythical.com
ear biscuits is brought to you by
betterhelp getting to know yourself it's
a lifelong process isn't it it is and
you know I was actually talking about
this with my wife last night oh yeah
that I recently uh sometimes it can be
alert yourself it can be a little bit
discouraging sometimes when you see how
much room there is for growth you'll be
like whoa I have a long way to go
but I was recently just had a moment of
gratitude that I'm like you know I'm a
middle-aged man 45 years old and I am
very excited about my personal growth
the growth that has taken place and the
growth that is to Comic it says it makes
me get excited about the rest of the
time that I have on this planet you're
saying you believe in therapy and
therapy has is the main reason that I'm
seeing things in that way
right specifically for me oh I I totally
agree I'm a huge fan of therapy you know
we talk about it a lot on this show and
we're a fan of accessible therapy so
that's why we're plugging better help
y'all he's entirely online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule you just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge ain't nothing wrong with
switching therapists it's a thing and
they make it easy discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com ear today to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp help
help.com ear
so let's talk a little bit about how we
got to this point from a practical
standpoint to this video
and how the team came together because
it's you know interestingly enough
especially as it relates to this first
video the team and one per person in
particular it ended up being very
important
uh so you know we worked on inside eats
last year on the Food Network we made
four episodes that was over the summer
two weeks in December we shot those four
episodes
yeah
just to give you an idea of how long it
takes this stuff to come together but as
we we're not gonna belabor the point and
talk about that in detail but I think
that it's an incredible juxtaposition
between what we're doing now because
this was an opportunity that we had
based on Food Network approaching us
they already had a show that was
essentially conceptualized they needed
hosts for it we said we'll do it if we
get to be executive producers and get to
be very involved in the creative process
long story short as much as we were
involved in the creative process we were
making a show for the Food Network and
the final product was very much what the
Food Network wanted in fact what they
wanted at many different turns usurped
what we wanted
and what we ended up getting is a
compromised product from our standpoint
right right and that's the nature of
work working in traditional media and
it's not a game that will never play
again but it's not the game we're
playing right now but the best there's
two things that came from that
experience the first thing it's just
another reminder of what it's like to go
through that process of developing
something for a traditional outlet and
going through the process of producing
it and it's it's just compared to the
independent Creator game
there's things that are better about it
certain things that are better about it
you know namely financially uh but
almost every other aspect of it is more
frustrating and less rewarding right
again not ruling it out there's still
pitches that are out there that are in
different stages whatever if they come
about we'll probably work on something
else but as compared to what we're doing
right now it's a completely different
process so it was that lesson that
reminder it was great that it was great
that that reminder came last year and
was kind of resonating in our minds as
we moved into this process yeah by the
time Thanksgiving of last year rolled
around we were starting to get very
specific about the plans that led to the
relaunch of the Rhett and Link channel
yeah uh at first we were thinking about
well we weren't thinking about where it
would be it wasn't really about the
Rhett and Link channel it was about
let's create things that we can put out
into the world like from start to finish
once we have the idea we know it will be
seen we know it will come to completion
we'll release it into the world it will
be created yeah
um and we will have
much more creative control than over
this the Food Network show which was the
only thing of all these these other
efforts that actually did come out and
people did get to see it right so we
well this is about the second piece from
that
was TJ TJ Chambers who was the
showrunner you know producer on inside
eats and
sometimes you work with people and you
just immediately have this creative
connection right and you you gel and you
basically realize that you're speaking
the same language and when you
communicate something they understand
what you're saying right they also come
up with ideas that are the kind of ideas
that you would come up with and we've
been doing this long enough to know that
that doesn't happen every day it's not
easy to do that we you know we've had
hundreds of people work at mythical
right and I think that
the number of people who you like you
get onto this creative wavelength with
that's a very small number of people
it's it's it's difficult to find those
people and we saw that in TJ and so we
said listen even before we really had an
idea of what we were doing with this
content strategy
we said we need to hire TJ we were
saying let's just figure out a way to to
get him to work at mythical
um even before we knew what we wanted
them to do so we started the
conversation yeah and it's funny because
he was very very close to taking another
job that would have taken him out of
town and uh basically eliminated him
from this from the the
potential of of working with us but we
planted seeds early enough that like it
it came together well it's funny I
haven't even thought about this because
there's some Serendipity in this as
we'll talk about with the idea
but now that I'm thinking about it
there's some Serendipity in the nature
of of the way that happened because we
ended up saying hey let's just have
lunch together
yeah and that was he came to the office
and had lunch with the two of us and
Stevie and that was when we said Hey
listen we don't have enough we don't
have a role right now but we anticipate
having a role probably in 2023 and we
just want to see where your your head's
at because we know that you do freelance
production work for TV and that's
typically what he's done I don't think
he's ever been
like a long-term employee somewhere at
least not recently he's been doing
freelance production
and he was like well it's this this
comes at an interesting time because I
actually owe someone a response to
whether or not I'm going to go and work
for them and it was digital it was it
was digital content and it required a
move
and he was like he was like I don't know
how I feel about it but it's a pretty
good deal in some respects and we're
like well when do you when are you
supposed to tell him he was like
technically today
yeah you know and it's like we had
scheduled this meeting based on our
schedules and he and it just coincided
to the day that he needed to send this
message message
and uh he ended up telling us later
we're like well I wish we could just say
yes you have a job here but we can't say
that so don't let that affect this
opportunity
but he ended up not taking it and one
thing led to another and now he is
leading that team which you can kind of
describe how that team came together
important for us to I mean
build a team because we didn't like our
existing team here at mythical no one
had enough margin to just like
say oh you're great for this and you're
not doing anything or you know there
were certain so we had to kind of pull
we had to pull things together we had to
pull TJ from outside
um and then Ben who was our DP and
co-director on lots of things just
celebrated 10 years
here at mythical he was hired by Stevie
like weeks after she started
um and he's been
in development and directing on the
mythical kitchen channel for a good
while and we were like okay but he but
just so you know he he was the one who
was
uh
essentially co-directing but you know
directing the photography and making a
lot of creative decisions on so many of
the classic Rhett and Link things like
OCD I'm on vacation those sketches we
did for that sketchtober back in
whatever year that was Buddy system
season one yeah DP yeah and also uh you
know he was our closest creative
collaborator on Hazel last year or
whenever that was right so we knew we we
needed him on this project so we had to
we had to like lay some groundwork to uh
migrate him off a mythical kitchen and
and backfill over there like Morgan
stepped into more of directing over
there and Elise stepped into more of um
in into a more developed role a lot of
people started moving up so it's like it
was kind of a fun little game which gave
people uh a lot of people opportunity
and then allowed him to kind of come
over here with us and like us to get
because we we talked about getting back
to our roots and like the way that we
used to do things and the way you we
used to work with Ben and like he met TJ
that that that
was seemed like they were hitting it off
and like we were off to a good start and
we've been talking to Jenna about her
being able to move into like expand her
roles and her contribution here so we
were like all right look at look at all
the stuff that you did in helping with
our Vlogs when we were doing those back
in back pre-pandemic and start a
pandemic
um
so it's like hey is there is there more
of a production role for you in this so
then Jenna comes over
to the team and um you know we're then
we just start having all these meetings
and then we uh and then we're bringing
in yeah and then we're bringing in other
layers of people like more camera work
with uh Dylan coming in and then in post
like he's editing as well yep he he and
Ben are editing and then um you know
bringing in help from other members of
the team after that too so there's
there's more people involved but you got
this like core team that we started
meeting together and talking about like
this is our vision we're not we don't
want to be beholden to a schedule we
want the creative to drive these ideas
but yeah I mean
one I mean give or take every month it
would be nice if something came out but
and and I also but we're not going to
really it's not going to be about a
schedule and I think this represents a
bit of a uh uh creative Resurgence of
the way that we work with Stevie as well
right yeah definitely because
with the the systems that we have built
at mythical and the way that Stevie is
so intimately involved with so many
things Beyond just the things that we're
working on directly right so very early
on Stevie established herself as the
person who could make creative decisions
with our full Trust
and so that she became an extension of
us
and back in the day it was very much all
this stuff that we're just kind of
dreaming up and then she was making
happen
and then we started doing so many other
things as a company that she had she's
been spread very thin for a really long
time and she's great at spreading
herself very thin and doing a lot of
really incredible work like a glaze but
we kind of got to this place where we're
off developing these things that might
end up being a TV show or whatever and
she was involved in that and would have
different points where she would get
involved but like the last time that
she was in a car with us going to a
shoot like it's just been so long I
don't know how many years it's been
right I mean yes she was there for hazel
but Hazel was like this blip on the
radar in sort of the Dark Ages in some
way from us just getting creative stuff
out there personally yeah so it's
interesting you know so as we we uh
you know she went on the shoot with us
which is just that's not something that
has happened in a really long time you
know what I mean like being able to be
there and be present for it and having a
a team of people that you want to work
with and that you want to
create an experience with you know I
think one of the things I've been
focused on is
finding joy in the process of what we're
doing you know and I think that comes
out in the actual video there's
conversations about like you know my
mindset is yes and I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna like hold on so tightly to what it
is that we're making that like it's only
about the final product I'd really want
to enjoy spreading our creative wings
and having people that we enjoy doing
that with being there with us well I
want to talk about that very thing of
like the way that this kind of video and
what we envision to be future videos
comes together in a way that doesn't
happen in any other medium
uh but first let's talk about the way
the idea came about because it was the
thing I hinted at in my
three-year deconstruction update as one
of the synchronicity things that was
happening I will say this was not our
first idea no no no it's still not our
second or third I I would say we had
maybe six or eight ideas I think we had
about 30 ideas oh yeah I guess you're
right I mean so I've been working on a
document over over last year just slowly
adding ideas right and then we had a
meeting where I kind of just like threw
them all out there and it's like what
resonated which was I mean there was a
bunch of really bad ideas in this
because it was there was no filter on
any of them but the point was the
breadth of type of our approach to
videos is pretty wide there's these are
not a set format this is not a series of
videos they are each Standalone
exercises in creativity where we can
like try something and learn something
and then maybe return to it or maybe
just take a lesson and move forward it's
very experimental so we had all we
couldn't land on we had like three or
four ideas that we felt like okay of the
first like six videos three or four
these are three or four of them but we
just didn't have what we felt was the
first video because so many people are
going to make decisions about this
whole effort based on this first video
and all of all those videos that we came
up with none of those felt like a great
first video right
so this is when we were we had we had a
meeting to come up with to sort of
establish like what are the first four
videos
and that was that day I took that power
nap right and when I woke up I had an
idea in my head and the idea that was in
my head was what if we just dug a hole
oh and I immediately
dismissed the idea in my own head never
I I was like well that's dumb and I
don't know what I don't know why I had
that idea and it just feels stupid and I
wasn't thinking about like an
anti-internet idea which will kind of
get to why we end up gravitating towards
this yeah but that was that was
literally the extent of it no
development no real consideration it was
just kind of plucked out of The Ether
but definitely very serious very much a
specific idea of what if we just dug a
hole and then later that day we had the
meeting and TJ starts the meeting with
saying
I have an idea and I love it
and I think he said I love it and it's
stupid and he had talked to Ben about it
uh-huh and bend it and crap on it and I
think he liked it too and I'm trying to
remember if when he's he pitched it did
he pitch the full title
I can't remember I think it was I think
he did
I can't remember
but he said
that's his story he essentially said
all that happens in the video is you
guys dig a hole
but you take the digging of the hole
incredibly seriously yes yeah that's
what it was you take it like it's it's
about the process and immediately we for
the first thing I thought was holy [__]
what's happening
you know and again listen wait this is
my ideas what you said you can't have it
no I I said that in after the meeting I
was like hey man I want you to know that
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna be in the
habit of claiming that I had an idea in
my sleep when every time you come up
with a great idea it's just it just
seemed weird to me and I thought it was
worth mentioning
and uh you know listen I'm not my world
view is not changing because of that
some people would be like well clearly
you guys there was a discussion about a
hole or somebody was digging a hole it
was in The Ether it was not just in The
Ether it was like in people's minds and
so whatever I don't really care it felt
awesome when it happened and it was like
really good and no one could explain
where like he couldn't explain where
that he got the idea from anything there
wasn't there's no no Source practical
source that any of us can point to right
so anyway so it's cool to think that
maybe there was an idea out there in The
Ether but I can't prove it and I don't
even care whether you believe it or not
so
but and you hadn't pitched it to me no
because I wasn't gonna pitch it anyway I
wasn't at the yeah you weren't gonna I
had dismissed the idea you weren't
stupid before I even became anything you
didn't mention it to me TJ didn't
mention anything to me I was at home so
I got on the video call you were you
were on a computer in in the meeting
yeah and then
um
he pitched it
is and that's when you told him
I love this idea because I had it
because I've already heard it because
I've already had it this morning while
taking a nap
um which is hilarious but but it
immediately resonated with all of us
because
we could
devote ourselves completely to the
creative exercise of something that was
so
low it was just
anti-climactic yeah
anti-sensational the fact that it was
like not a it didn't seem like even in a
best case scenario when you try as hard
as you can it's not like this thing is
going to break the Internet it's not
going to be and so it's not but from the
ground up it's not a manipulative
exercise it could it was freed up to be
a more of a creative exercise in the
journey we're taking you on than in the
destination because we already told you
at the top at the top right there we dug
a medium-sized hole set your
expectations low that's not what this
this is not about you getting wowed and
you feeling like this is something
you've never seen before it's not about
the whole it's about how we go about it
so then we wanted to surprise you and
reward the viewer with this journey of
I mean really I I've been seeing it so
much but creative expression it's like
what can we do how how much fun can we
have with this inconsequential idea and
I don't think I don't know if it made it
in the final edit it wasn't there at one
point
but I'll acknowledge it here because
it's based this this
so the
of all the videos that you can watch on
the internet on YouTube of people
digging holes the ones that will pop up
when you search are going to be much
more the whole is going to be much more
impressive than what we did in the video
right I mean first of all there's those
channels where which are mesmerizing
which is sort of like uh primitive
technology on crack
where they're somewhere I don't know
what country they're in and they dig
these crazy holes in this really really
awesome like clay and they make these
incredible like apartments with
hot tubs and sinks and fireplace and
stuff you know I don't know what channel
it is there's multiple channels where
they where they do it and that is so
much not what we did and so
this isn't you know and of course if Mr
Beast were to dig a hole he's going to
dig the biggest hole in the world and
like put a bunch of people in there and
the last person to get out is gonna
or the first person to get out it's
going to win a million dollars I don't
know how it's going to work but that's
also not what we're doing right why
would it be the first person well the
last person to leave the whole if you're
in a hole you're trying to get out of
the hole oh really Mr Beast will come up
with that video and it'll be great and
it'll get a hundred million views our
video is not going to get 100 million
views it's not intended to get 100
million views we couldn't get 100
million views if we devoted the rest of
our lives to it I'm convinced of that
that's not what we're good at right
we're not good at getting 100 million
views but maybe over time but not in one
video right so
the whole that's cool man the whole
thing was like an ante and an anti not
anti-comedy hopefully but and you know
anti-internet video in many different
ways but the thing that you were getting
at a second ago were the way that the
different parts uh that that was I think
this is something I'm so excited about
because one of the things that has
happened every single time we've been in
a room with someone talking about an
idea is there has been this predominant
confusion from the development people
that we're talking to as to what role we
play because in traditional
entertainment you have a director you
have a writer you have the actors you
have a producer and sometimes you might
get a director a writer director and
then very very occasionally if someone
was an actor and then they decide to
direct they might be a writer director
actor or a director actor
but you have to climb so many different
rungs of the ladders in this town in
order to get the privilege to be able to
do that right and sometimes actors with
American accents are British most of the
time actually most American actors are
British
but the that doesn't none of those rules
none of those expectations and none of
those restrictions apply to YouTube
we've always just said what is the way
that makes sense for us to bring this
idea into the world and for us that's
been we know what we're good at we know
the pieces of the puzzle that we bring
to the table and we know how to empower
other people who are better at different
things in order to bring something to
the to the table and that's why
the video looks the way that it looks
because of Ben right and also Ben is
directing us in a lot of different
aspects right
there are these moments where we'll be
like let's come together and we're this
like three-headed monster who's making
these decisions together in sync kind of
as like one directorial force
but it's such an ease and then Stevie if
if she's there she's gonna and she's got
an idea we respect her ideas and her
perspective too from a like executive
producer level and this is a really easy
conversation that we have honed over
years and then TJ folds into that really
really easily and I'm I'm saying that
because that's not how traditional film
sets work there's one person who's in
charge it's a hierarchy and I think
there's just something about the way
we've always worked with the fact right
from the top there's two of us that are
constantly compromising with one another
and constantly that's right working
together there's not one of us that's in
charge of anything and so that we come
into this with this collaborative
mentality that if we trust someone
creatively the collaborative mentality
spills over into their lap too and it
doesn't become the too many cooks in the
kitchen sometimes maybe in post in the
edit it can get a little bit it can get
a little too many cooks in the kitchen
but I don't really think that happened
on this one but there were moments when
it's like okay there's four or five
people with an idea
but we ended up getting uh what we all
felt was best uh ultimately
but I just love the fact that we can
know and then things like the song so
well even before we get to that I'd like
the planning part I really enjoyed being
in a room and trying to land on what
this thing was it's like you have this
idea and you have these you have ideas
that you want to explore within it
um and maybe there's a little bit of
commentary that we're throwing out there
about
internet videos in general and we're all
there's also a lot of self-deprecating
humor about what we do I mean like the
magnet thing obviously was like just
intended to be it's real but it's
intended to be a joke making fun of
ourselves and the internet video culture
but I had a lot of fun tossing like
tossing out ideas in the room and trying
to get on the same page about what the
overall tone
feel
Vibe of this video is going to be like
what's the what's the voice here you
know what's the
how is it gonna feel when it all comes
together and every time you're throwing
out ideas you're like that doesn't fit
what I think I'm picturing that I want
to feel like when I when I watch this
thing the vibe yeah so it's I there's a
lot of fun in that of like because it
could go in so many different directions
and you just start to like chip away at
the Rock to form
what it is this is very unique style and
tone of video that I hope is very fresh
and different than you can't really
compare to any one thing out there and
the the genre right so right this
I think there's there's there's two
things that go into this I mean first of
all I think our mentality with this
video and with the these videos in
general and I'm not saying every single
video is going to do this but
as a whole this effort
is I think is characterized by us saying
what do we do well or what do we think
we do well you know like we we think we
do a few things well
and we would like to be able to throw
those things at these ideas and
sometimes one idea will catch all the
things that we think that we do well are
the things that we want to do in the
ways that we want to express ourselves
and again in in comparison to
traditional Hollywood
you don't there's some people breaking
the mold but we have to come into a
situation and be like well we're this is
all scripted or this is all unscripted
uh and we always have this desire to be
like why does it have to be one thing
so obviously the backbone of this video
is an unscripted docu-reality following
us the process
documenting the process of us digging a
hole but we didn't want to make it Vlogs
2.0 right we so we didn't want to film
ourselves but more importantly than that
we didn't just want to do that again
we've done it that wasn't but we wanted
to take what we learned from that and
it could impact our approach to the the
docu reality part of this like the fact
that we are honestly and sincerely
setting out to dig a hole yeah we're not
faking it we're not getting somebody
else to dig the hole for us and then you
know yeah this is a this is a legitimate
exercise in something silly so so we
definitely pulled from the Vlogs but we
definitely didn't want to go back there
and do more of it and you know what I
think it's it's fitting that you
mentioned that especially before it's
out into the world because I'm just
gonna go ahead and prepare you and me
for the response from some fans and I
don't have anything against these fans
I'm just letting you know that there are
going to be people who are like it's not
the Vlogs and I don't like it as much
because it's not the Vlogs Rhett and
Link don't have a camera they're not
filming themselves it feels too produced
what we're gonna get those com those
comments because and it's like you know
what it is more produced than the vlogs
on purpose this is a different exercise
a lot some of the videos are not good
some of these things that we're gonna
make aren't going to be
reality at all are going to be
completely scripted you know we are
throwing a lot of things at the wall and
there might be oh well this this one we
made we do have cameras and we are
filming ourselves we we're going to do
it for we're going to do whatever we
think serves that idea the best right
and so this isn't to say that you're
wrong if you feel one thing's better
than or another or you want you want
more Vlogs or I'm saying this is not
that we're scratching itches and we're
doing something that is a again we've
got a vehicle that's just us being
ourselves this good mythical morning we
want a creative expression vehicle and
that's what this is and so just letting
you know when you make that comment
which I know people will that's how we
feel about what you're saying and that's
how we're considering it meaning we we
understand that opinion but we're not
taking it into account I'm just being
honest with you we this is a creative
expression it's not the vlogs
so we're getting uh we're getting the
shots or Ben and Dylan are getting the
shots
to create a different product versus us
like hey I'm going over to Link's house
and I got my camera and I'm feeling
myself in my car that's not the vibe for
this
but and then we have these other itches
like oh we should we should we should
get some music in this yeah we should
have some we you know like keeping
people guessing with the things that we
can be excited about putting in there
and shifting genres so like the music
video thing was a lot of fun you know
it's like it was it was easy to it was
easy to write it was it was fun to
produce and then we got to work with
Mark Byers on producing that thing and
like getting it to be this that's a
that's a whole experience in and of it
so Mark did produce all the music for
buddy system
you know all the music for the music
videos for season one and two and we've
collaborated with him a lot yeah and and
I don't there's a few things I want to
kind of keep behind the curtain right
which is what parts of the video right
uh uh were predetermined and the song is
a great example
um
did we sing a song in the field
and then come back and finish it
knowing we were going to make it into a
music video and then just get some get
some shots well that would help explain
the fact that we're not lip syncing
anything once we start singing we're
just doing weird stuff with shovels Etc
right or maybe we did maybe we wrote the
whole thing ahead of time and we wanted
it to seem like we were running in the
moment
there's multiple moments throughout
these videos that are going to be that
way and all we're interested in
is just a Vibe right it's not about
making you think a certain thing
you think whatever it is you want to
think about it we are creating something
that sends that you know it's the
product that we want to create and yeah
I think I'm much more interested in
getting people to feel something than to
think something yeah so I think that and
it's
I don't know that I've ever
said that about something that we've
made before I think that's
that's an exciting part of this is that
if we bring
all of ourselves to it like the honest
sincere parts and the creative parts and
the unexpected parts and the twists and
turns and the silliness and what
whatever it is like I'm I'm interested
in what what is this trying to create a
pure expression a creativity what does
it make people feel
you know and that's exciting to me and I
think that if I can interact with the
response in that way
that would be a healthy way to do it
versus like did enough people get it
versus and and a lot of comments aren't
really they're not typically about
feelings you know
sometimes they are but like a video
about digging a medium-sized hole how
many comments are we gonna get about how
it made you feel like I don't
I almost don't like saying this because
I feel like I'm asking people to do that
and I'd rather have not said it and just
uh that that's what I'm after and maybe
if it doesn't come through the comments
that's because people don't comment
enough about their feelings is what I'm
going to say but uh yeah so writing like
like having music or being able to
produce that
um yeah just having a and then The
Surreal elements like towards the end
you know saying hey we can we can we can
play in in this sandbox like I think
we're gonna have to literally build a
sandbox
for someone else to play in yeah so that
particular uh that particular scene you
know with the the mole with a puppet I
don't really
because I'm not a fan of Puppets
you know
but I'm I'm made that clear I'm a fan of
this puppet and I don't think I might
have any like
I don't know I'm not a fan of
acapella either I don't want to have any
acapella in it but we've done that to
kind of kind of do I mean it's got some
stuff but it essentially is like a
old-school acapella song but that
particular you know the decision to do
that
again it was this all right well we like
making scripted stuff like we've always
made love making scripted stuff
are we is it what we're best love making
scripted is it is it what we're best at
scripted love making no we're we're not
like if you if you I think when you
think about things that we're really
good at I think good mythical morning
and making a show like good mythical
morning I think we're really really good
at playing that role in that way
compared to like other people in the
entertainment business but the
entertainment business in the scripted
world there's so many more peop people
who are way better at that than we are
but we love doing it right now sometimes
if we throw ourselves completely at like
a completely scripted project it exposes
some of our weaknesses and in one way or
another right
but I think that when we're like hey
we've got this isolated moment
where we can call on a favor from a
friend and that friend happens to be
Tony Hale
um you know who's he's got some pretty
recognizable uh voice over work yeah
um to be the voice of this mole
that is just something that is exciting
to us like being able to say hey let's
write this really short thing that's
like 90 seconds or whatever let's send
the script to Tony he's
in Rome working on a film and he's gonna
just do the voice into his iPhone and
that's what we're gonna use you know and
it's gonna be good enough and it and
it's going to create this weird moment
and then we're gonna get Dad magic now
first of all if you want to know the
story of the puppet
in the trials and tribulations of said
puppet yeah being a member of the
mythical Society this is another this is
another reason to be a member of the
mythical Society because the behind the
scenes for this video and specifically
that moment is something that unfolds in
a BTS on
uh on the mythical society and by the
way that is what we're going to be doing
for all these videos so there's going to
be
not always going to be behind the scenes
but like certain stories from the
from the
from each video I think the story of the
mole and like how it came to life and I
guess died
but maybe they've already watched it but
yes uh mythical Society is going to have
that for every single video and and if
you like we have a we also plan to be
able to discuss and go into more detail
about these videos on beer biscuits when
it makes sense I mean right now we're
talking a lot we've been talking a lot
about like the whole idea in the in the
whole initiative moving forward since
we've done that we'll be talking more
about the specific thing that we're
making if if it warrants in your biscuit
which I think for a lot of these it will
uh but yeah I in in being able to see
that in fact as we're recording this it
was just yesterday
where we
um saw the final film the final scene
with the with the puppet because of as
you'll see on the mythical Society
things didn't necessarily go as planned
the first time
uh but that seeing that and right now
when we watch the edit it's just it says
mole footage on the screen really big
when you hear Tony talking but then you
just see the footage of us on the other
end of the shovel right
but I just I personally love
the fact that it goes from this oh we
think we're done to no we're not done
and now we're talking to this mole I
just I love stuff like that so much and
to be able to put it in something and
not to not have to ask anyone's
permission and just it's in the world
and he's he's a dirty mole yeah yeah
I mean what what would you expect I mean
he's got a dirty mouth dirty mouth he's
got a dirty he's got dirty fur
he's got a furry butthole that's dirty
uh but yeah he's uh he's he's got he's
got some spicy like kiss my Dirty Heads
he's dirty he's a dirty mole
what was your favorite part of this
whole thing so far
or now that it's done
I think that
and it's funny because I don't think
I've yet I haven't experienced it yet
because we haven't seen the final thing
that's going out because we haven't had
the final music uh laid in from Mark and
we haven't had the final mole footage
edited in because we just recorded it
yesterday
but I think for me my favorite
part of all of this I mean first of all
I'm I love the the initial phases of
conceptualizing things I that that's
always going to be like the most
exciting thing for me like the initial
idea and then the sort of initial like
as it comes together oh and then this
will happen and then this will happen
and they'll all know and then we'll
bring in this other thing like that is
super exciting I'm most engaged then
and then sometimes it's like well
there's process that goes into making
things actually happen and you know I I
I'm I'm like okay yeah okay whatever
yeah like now let's get to the final
product of how it all comes together
so the other book in for me that is so
enjoyable is when we can watch what we
made and have a feeling about it yeah
one of my favorite Parts was uh and
Jenna I'm gonna ask you what your
favorite part is so heads up okay
um
when instead of just sending out a link
for people to write edit notes and then
like we all got in a room
and we screened it yeah we watched it
together and to me that was important
because it's the camaraderie of we're
making this thing together we're all
invested in it and then we're watching
it together and you get you get laughter
in the room you get reactions you
actually learn things from that and it
becomes it makes the final product
better but the main reason I wanted to
do it is because it would just be a fun
way to give notes you know
uh and I just think it was uh it was
more profitable too but
um I also had
a lot of fun on the excavator
yeah I think that was uh
yeah that was that was risky yeah that
was fun that was that was that was one
of my most fun Parts I actually had I
think during the making of it my most
fun part was when you were on the
excavator and I was mimicking you yeah
on the ground oh well and I didn't I
didn't know until after some of that you
were doing that some of that you know
some of that is in the edit which is
great uh oh you wanted more of that but
you want your own well the funny thing
is is I it took a while and I did so
much like interpretive days are you sore
I wasn't sore I was exhausted I mean
there could be a cut
you probably didn't dig for an hour but
it was at least half an hour and
I basically was doing this dance thing
just like
feeding off of the energy of you and the
excavator
and digging my own little hole it was
beautiful rap and it was beautiful I was
it was pure I think what I didn't see
you at the time but it was it was pure
joy post it was pure joy I knew that
some of it was going to make it into the
edit and so it was performative yeah in
one sense but
the majority of what I was feeling at
that time I think it was a interpretive
dance expression of the way I feel about
the fact that we're getting to do this
that we finally enlisted we only have
ourselves to blame and I don't blame
ourselves that I'd have no regrets
because people might be like why didn't
you start making stuff like this earlier
why did you try to do all this other
stuff
there's a time for everything right it's
like this is coming it's just a scratch
this is coming exactly the right time
I've never been more excited about
what we do creatively
but I think that the the interpretive
dance
which felt the funny thing is like I
remember going over to like I heard
Stevie laughing because he was all MOS
so it didn't matter that people were
making noise by the way the excavator
was making quite a lot of noise too yes
but I just remember going over to Stevie
and I was like I hope that was as funny
as it felt you know like
sometimes you're just doing something
and again it might just it's this little
almost incidental moment in this thing
but I was just having so much fun
because again that wasn't planned it
wasn't like we were we only one there
was a point in which we thought we would
have both of us in the excavator at the
same time because it would be funny to
be like oh they they have they can't
they all have to share everything and
they couldn't decide who was going to
run the excavator but it's not safe
that's not a safe way to run an
excavator
no it's also not terribly safe to have
someone like within the range of the
bucket in the arm dancing with their
eyes closed especially when you're
operating things at times I was
completely in the moment yeah man dude
that was done uh
but again I was like what am I going to
do I've had to do something I have to
interact with this were you scared for
him Jenna there were a few moments when
I was like I I did the whole safety
briefing yeah and now the safety
breakout was completely out of my mind
at that time yeah
but that but again that was just one of
those there's the things that you plan
and there's the things that you don't
plan and it's funny because one of my
favorite parts of the video
um is
when I come back with the other
excavator and then you do the same you
do you do your own like interpretive
thing the dinking and think it was a
good moment that was it yeah yeah yeah
TJ came over and was like he's like
yelling at me he was like I you should
probably do like a deacon and sink it
I'm like I love you with your shuttles
you're with your shovel yeah
um
Jenny Jenny hey hey Jenny Jenny that's
what we're calling Jenna on this project
her code name is Jenny Jenny what was
your favorite my code name for the uh
shoot was the the shoveler yeah you were
she taught us how to properly properly
transport shovels yes yeah we had a
whole safety briefing yeah how to hold
it TJ TJ's nickname was scoops
okay you guys double got the whole thing
yeah I was the shoveler yeah you hold
the shovel with the Spade part down yes
you walk with it vertically
yeah don't don't put it over your
shoulder nope don't put it under your
shoulder
hold it in the middle of the handle with
this with the Spade part down at the
ground and nobody got hurt nobody got
hurt was that your favorite part that
nobody got hurt that
was yes I loved that nobody got hurt
that was great but I also loved uh being
able to uh ride the excavator as well I
get you positioned it and then you you
filled up the hole right TJ and I filled
up the holes yeah it was uh like dark
and uh the sun was like there was just a
little bit of sun left I mean we could
have done it we just wanted you to have
your fun I I literally did I literally
wanted to fill in that hole and I was
like I know that I know that Jenna and
TJ want to do this it was fun but yeah
it did take all night plus um I ended up
having to stay overnight with the
excavators for security reasons but you
you stated in our the RV yeah yeah but
you were uh alone and I gave you uh a
big knife yes which I loved it's such a
cool knife I have a giant if you want to
get that for me for my birthday I do
like a giant hunting knife in the FJ and
like the camping uh area I took a photo
of myself with it and sent it to Laura
and I was like hey don't worry I'm I'm
in the desert but I have this huge knife
with me it's a big knife I mean
I slept with it next to me and I slept
so good
it was sheathed though it was sheets
okay yes yes I want to be grabbing that
thing you don't want to take knife
advice from me that's a bad sign when
I'm the one telling he's not allowed to
touch that knife no it would not do with
the knife
um so that was your favorite part I'd
say that and uh
uh yeah I think nothing related to me
okay
now I loved watching it as well like
watching it all back and hearing
everyone laughing and getting the
reactions it was really nice we because
yeah we usually don't do that for yeah
it's just like we're getting it we're
getting to experience the different
stages of a creative process including
not committing to a schedule you've
mentioned that earlier but I think it's
important because
everything that we've done over the past
10 years
has been like we're doing this and we're
doing it every week we're doing this and
we're doing it every single day yeah and
that's not the deal with this we're
approaching this and the Cadence of the
release of these videos and the process
of development of each one of these
videos as if we have this portion of
ourselves and our company that is
cordoned off as a traditional YouTube
Creator most of the YouTube channels
that you watch
you know they might be like oh every
Tuesdays or Thursdays but usually
they're like guys sorry it's late this
week or whatever we're actually
embracing a little bit of the chaos
of the earliness of our career where it
was like you have an idea you figure out
what it takes to make it you make it in
a certain amount of time whatever it
takes you and then when you get it right
you release it and that's what we're
doing with these things we're not overly
committing to a schedule where by which
we become
essentially
beholden to meeting this Cadence and
that's one thing sometimes don't they
they don't get as fun we want this to
remain fun
uh because we want to stay really
engaged with it and we have so many
things that we want to do already
so many things that we want to do I'm
excited already about the next one and
the next one and I maybe even the next
one
but like the the next one
is you know there's a there's a the
amount of risk involved you know the
fact that like there's a general there's
a genuine question
we don't know how it's going to go of
how this is going to go is very exciting
um we're not in control of everything
that happens I'm actually exploring like
the concept of and talking about some in
therapy about like how do you how do I
understand the difference between
anxiety and excitement because they show
up in very similar ways in your body
you know you start to feel like you got
butterflies you know like I lose my
appetite and I wake up and like I have
this like
huh if I feel like things are out of
control I'll have like a free-falling
kind of a feeling but just a nervousness
devoid of the Free Fall feeling I think
is just that I'm so freaking excited
about the fact that we're taking a
genuine risk
here and we don't you know it's a it's a
dynamic question that we don't know what
the answer is
and that's gonna that's gonna be that
that's why we're that's why we're doing
it
you know and then we're sharing it once
we know
so I don't want to tease it any more
than that but that's how I look at it uh
because I mean
tomorrow we're going out and shooting
part of that yeah yeah we're all I mean
so we're kind of again it's good to stop
and celebrate because we're on to the
next they're overlapping because again
while I said we're not committing to a
Cadence you know we do have like four
videos planned right now that and then
you know we're we're gonna try to like
link said uh hope to get to like once a
month but
um there's gonna be there's multiple
things in process on multiple videos
right now we're planning and then you
gotta shoot and then you're looking at
the edit and I don't know things are
going to get very busy but and they
already are but it's doing things that
we're so excited about that it doesn't
feel like work
you know just doesn't feel like work
it's a good place to be I'm very very
very very excited so thanks for giving
it a watch or multiple watches and
sharing it with people
um
and yes letting us know what you think
and what you feel it's called we dig a
what is it we dig we dug we dug we dug
we dug a medium-sized hole yeah wherever
you get your YouTube videos that's not
what I remember my recommendation but
um And subscribe to that red Link
channel by the way we we need to do it
yeah you know it's been stuck just under
5 million subscribers for uh a very long
time
uh so you know we made a decision to
tell your people to not put this on like
we could have put it on like the weekend
a good mythical morning and it would
probably get more views initially but
this is a different thing so we're
putting it in a different place but
there's a lot of stagnant accounts over
there because it's such an old channel
that hey subscribe to it tell your
people to subscribe to freshen it up
also of course let us know what
resonated with you in this creativity
conversation using your biscuits and you
can call us and leave a voicemail one
eight eight
earpod one can I give a wreck yeah
my favorite thing on Tick Tock and I've
mentioned this before
um
if I've wrecked it before so be it it
keeps coming up for me
on Tick Tock SB mowing as in lawn mowing
it's got two and a half million
followers
um
and what he does is this this dude goes
to Lawns that are overgrown and just
totally uh neglected he popped up
recently when the neighbor came out to
him and got mad at him right because he
was the same guy yep yep making too much
noise with a weed whacker making too
much noise with the weed wrap yeah
and then it's it's like time-lapse video
of him
free of charge
fixing dilapidated Lawns and like edging
the freaking sidewalks it makes me so
happy and knowing that he's doing it for
free for these people who obviously they
they just they just don't have the
ability or you know whatever their story
is to be able to like keep their lawn up
it's just so satisfying to see a
complete complete landscape finished and
it's just it's it's a form of cleaning
video and altruism
SB mowing
and then he's got a YouTube channel too
youtube.com
C slash SB mowing I've never been more
of the same I think it's longer full
videos with the homeowner's reactions oh
damn oh crap I haven't even gotten into
that yet haven't gotten off a tick tock
there we go all right thank you all for
celebrating with us
hi guys my name is Kate AC I just
finished listening to the episode where
Rhett talks about going to the Carolina
basketball game the feeling that he is
describing is something called
Collective effervescence which is where
a group of people have a shared purpose
and experience the same sorts of
feelings because they're all doing the
same thing you can experience it at
concerts religious services and yes even
basketball games bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the secular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign